well let's let's let's let's talk about
this california declares drought
emergency across
vast swath of state we talked a lot
about
political crises but what happens so uh
let me let me silencing i don't want to
blame joe biden for everything
i think he's a bad leader i think his
policies have caused very serious
problems with the economy and with the
border of course
i don't think we can blame him for
everything having to do with israel and
gaza that would be insane that
conflict's been going on for a long time
but what we're looking at now with this
story from california there's a massive
drought
i look at some of these photos and i was
i went and covered the drought several
years ago
when it was you know in its in its peak
it was it was a disaster
and it looks worse now i mean maybe i'm
wrong maybe maybe maybe it's just
misremembering but it seems like it's
way worse what are we going to do now
when we have this pathetic
president who has no ability to lead how
is he supposed to deal with his own
problems of his creation
and with natural disasters because
california's
they're already in trouble yeah now you
add this drought
they're going to start going to other
states and making demands and they're in
demand relief they're mad and we pay for
it that drought that you said you
covered and i'm trying what was that
about
probably about a decade ago it was well
no no it was uh 2016.
20 the 2015-2016 what steps did the
state of california ordered america take
after that drought to say how do we make
sure this doesn't happen again
right like i said earlier on one of the
things i challenge my challenge in this
industry is that it's not always
sexy it's not titillating it's not fun
that's another example and this
is the role of government right the role
of government is not to police your
pronouns
it is not to talk about your your your
boys and girls in sports
these are for good or for ill these are
the jobs we've put at the feet of our
government
what has california or the country done
to secure our electric grid
to secure our energy supply or in the
case of california to secure its water
supply
because you know you are drought prone
you know what your population is you
know that
the the rain is cyclical i want to make
sure i highlight the other story in this
because this is about the greater
natural disasters and we have this one
from
express.uk solar storm traveling at 1.3
million kilometers per hour to hit earth
tomorrow oh great
they say it could spark
satellite-related issues sometimes when
we get these
when we get these storms it causes
issues with like cell phone coverage and
things like that
i don't think this is the big one where
all of our electronics get fried or
anything
but just another example of outside of
the political crisis
and the government to your answer to
your question not doing anything about
it
and uh i'm not i'm not comfortable right
now
with a biden presidency a bite
administration as we're staring down the
barrel of natural disasters
middle eastern conflict economic crisis
migrant crisis
i'm actually what um what's the opposite
of comfortable um
uncomfortable isn't it disconcerted
that's good no not not enough
agitated uh anxious and
genuinely concerned but you know i would
say i'm not
a uh uh particularly excitable
so when it happens i kind of laugh and
then i go and buy a bunch of bullets
you know that was my reaction today like
i did my segments so i do
my my you know you know hour and 20
minutes or so in the morning with three
segments ten one
and four pm and afterwards i was like do
ammo.com let's see nine millimeter
hollow point
let's see 45 acp oh yes and you got it
no problem
there's a lot of shortages yeah yeah
it's been a little bit better it was
really bad last year but i was like i'm
going to buy a bunch of bullets
and then i got like some beans and rice
and i'm like you know what man
that's that's that's that's the
manifestation of my anxiety watching
abide in presidency and natural
disasters
i'm like time to buy some ammo you're
not wrong either the
historically if you ever i won't tell
you about the sea peoples have you guys
ever heard of the sea peoples
1200 bc people yeah apparently this
unknown culture of humans 1200 bc
came from the from asia and just flooded
the mediterranean and wiped out and
murdered and destroyed
all civilization essentially as we know
it they don't know why
no one really knows anything about them
or where they came from or why they came
but what they think happened was a
series of events
it's never the big one it's very rarely
it's a volcano along with uh
three years of famine and then there's a
flood or there's a war
involved with a famine and then there's
a solar flare
or there's a fire and it's all these
things happening at once
that's what causes social collapse it's
not it's not the the
oil alone it's not the solar flare alone
it's not the war alone but it's when
they all
conflict and they're all happening right
now isn't that isn't that perfect
any moment they can all happen right now
we have to be on guard for that
and that's and that's like why i think
biden is particularly bad for us
i understand it's like so obvious tim
poole criticizing joe biden i get it
um i think trump had his problems but
joe biden is like
sitting in his wheelchair with his
little warm blanket and the sun going
like while like everything's on fire
yosemite erupts and then there's
uh if somebody erupts we've got nothing
to worry about yeah be back and there's
a wall
and a flood we all have masks so if
yosemite erupts we have
we have masks it could block out at the
very least other than the actual i mean
for for i don't know how long it would
block out the sun
um that would destroy a crop so you're
saying the secret bunker should be
hermetically sealable so that we can
go underground and yes indoor farms
prolong our suffering
indoor farms is a big part of it it's
going to be a race to get to mount
weather if
if mount if yellowstone uh and yosemite
goes up
also heading off now whether that's the
station uh in virginia it's actually
um right outside dc but that's what the
government built in the case of nuclear
war mount weather you can see it it's
right there on a hill it's a secret
government it's not secret because
everyone knows what it is
what's happening you know it's well it's
on a mountain and it's called mount
weather and it's it's one of those
what actually happens in mount weather
no one is that where the island is a
government bunker
is that where the enclave is involved
that's awesome yeah you go if you go far
west of the mountains and there's like a
yeah that's what it is the thing that
concerns me is i don't think we should
even talk about if
it's when when yosemite erupts because
it will again in the future
volcanoes do it's overdue by only like
80 000 years so there's nothing to worry
about when there's a conflux of events
that causes mass catastrophe on the
surface of earth hopefully we'll be on
mars we'll be in the moon web space
stations but yeah
what are we where's our localized
infrastructure i don't want to rely on a
pipeline i don't want to rely on an
energy
source far away i mean where's my will
food my water
my waist just real quick yes mount
weather is what they use to model
raven rock which in fallout 3 for those
that are familiar with the game is where
the enclave which is the remnants of the
us government
are based yes after the nuclear
apocalypse there you go yeah that's
always a real place but they're not
going to let you in
well no we're going to try to get in
maybe
but but to your point though absolutely
if if
if societal collapse happens
it's it is every man for himself and
that is why teaching
self resiliency and and and and
independence
is a is a virtue and i feel like what we
are cult inculcating as a culture and i
feel like what this president is doing
is inculcating dependency we last night
we will take care of you about africa a
lot and like i think nigeria how they're
on crypto and a lot of what's happened
in these african countries is they've
leapfrogged the last 100 years of
electrical infrastructure because they
didn't have
a central grid so they just immediately
went to solar panel on every house
and now they all have cell phones yeah
yeah they bypass
like the telephone uh you know
centralization structure so they have
cell phones
solar panels they're using crypto so
there is potential for new societies to
have
to start with you know sustainable stuff
as we can see in the gravity lights
gravity lights are really cool you ever
see those
no it's a series of gears and that you
have a rock
on a string and you lift the rock up and
let it go
and as the rock is falling it's spinning
the gears which
generate electricity and it falls right
into 12 hours yeah it takes 12 hours to
go all the way down there's
lights it turns the light on so it's
like an old clock like an old
right right clock that has a pendulum
and has yeah yeah
so it's just using gear a gear you know
ratio
so that as it's spinning it goes really
slow it spins really fast and then
and gravity like the thing about
something in orbit is it's falling
technically when you're orbiting the
earth you're in a state of falling so if
we could utilize that force
to create electricity i think that oh
yeah sustainable you couldn't because
it is falling but it's moving forward
fast enough to where it
orbits you'd have to you'd have to
reduce speed at some point you can't
just
it that would be perpetual motion
machine it wouldn't work you can't just
get energy out of the system it would be
perpetual it would slow down over time
but it might slow down
like as the as the rock falls it takes
12 hours to fall maybe it could take
600 000 years for it to fall back to
earth i see just like orbital decay
mm-hmm
and then like capturing that somehow i
don't know maybe
seems kind of crazy yeah but uh maybe
we'll get by a solar storm and then
it'll
erase i think it wiped out going back to
the california droughts i mean there are
whole countries i'm thinking of israel
that have mastered desalinization yeah
but you know the problem with that is i
actually why can't we in california
they do have one in carlsbad i went
there it's beautiful it's it's crazy
it's a whole bunch of
it's a series of tubes as most things
are i suppose uh the internet
the other pipelines but they have a
whole bunch of these tubes where the
water runs
through all of them the problem is there
is going to be refuse
brine yeah and it we watched it we
filmed it as it poured out of these
these wastewater pipes the brine sinks
to the bottom and goes
under the ocean water killing everything
on the ocean floor
and that causes a wave of death going
all the way up because
the food chain dies the critters that
eat stuff on the floor die because
there's no food anymore the critters
that eat those craters die the critters
those critters that die and then the
people who go fishing can't get fish
anymore
so there's a lot of things to solve with
uh desalination
one of the issues i suppose is humans
consuming more and more of the ocean
water
changing salinity destroying coastal
areas destroying fisheries
i don't think there's a solute there
there's a solution for
infinite growth or at least exponential
growth considering how many people there
are i think there's a certain point
where we just get too many people and
then we strain our ecosystem
it happens to deer it happens to you
know basically every
creature on the planet hogs for instance
people go around helicopters shooting
hogs just too many of them
humans are not going to be immune from
the same environmental forces that
everything else on the planet is
and so we got to pay attention to that
i'm not going to prune into the
solutions but i can tell you a lot of
really
crazy people are willing to do a lot of
really crazy things once they get power
to ensure that they get to live
comfortably forever and you are the one
who is the hog being culled
yeah they're the ones who have the
private jets
and the that's right the multiple this
is what i think this is what i think
about the climate change thing i think a
lot of these people are like
you know there's like a guy and he's
like cities wearing his like velvet
bathrobe or whatever in the morning and
he's sipping his his morning coffee
with a cigar and then he sees the
newspaper and it says due to climate
change people will lose access to these
luxuries and he goes
heavens i have to give up my private jet
no make everyone else give it up so he
throws money and says everyone give up
all your luxuries give up all your
luxuries and he goes
once they all give up their luxuries and
they're flushing their toilets
and now you got to pee in the top of the
toilet to flush the rest of it because
we got to save water
i'll get to keep my yacht i'll get to
keep my private plane
it's better this way by the way that's a
wonderful accent of a rich person yeah
it was good i mean
that's just that's flawless rich people
naturally develop those accents oh yeah
yes as soon as you break your first
million
you should go to a club and there'll be
a guy and he's like well i'm looking at
my portfolio here and uh oh it's about
to cross one million dollars
it's happened surely good oh rufus your
voice broke i see you've made a million
dollars
there's a woman and she's like oh you
made a million dollars and he's like you
can tell can't you
when the when the rich psycho says i
need to
rule all these these sycophants these
people
because they're not smart enough and
then they make these decisions like if
they give up their
what's that bloomberg yeah yeah so when
that happens i wonder like then you were
talking about all these people that just
can't stop eating crap
salty fast food they can't like bring
themselves to change to become
self-identified to cook their own food
to take control of their life
are they really like a mass of
ignoramuses that need to be
controlled and called not called but
like taken taken care of by
a small group of highly intelligent
humans or is that a story we're told
that's a really good point i think
uh maybe you're on to something ian
there could be a group of people
that maybe just have better ideas it
could be a reference to like
enlightenment
or you know like like a light like an
illumination
they could call themselves something
like that like illumi lumen illumination
guys or something
the illuminati yeah yeah the ones who
know all things
yes yes and they can tell other people
how to live
because as we've seen throughout history
centralization of power
always is a good okay if you hoard all
your information on an island then
there's no chance the island will get
flooded and destroyed and that the
information will be lost
or in a great library perhaps uh the
problem with these people is that
while i think it's true there are a lot
of really really dumb people and i think
there are very few smarter people
centralization doesn't work one person
a small group of people cannot
adequately plan
for how a system this large will work
they've tried it over and over again
it was called communism it clearly
doesn't doesn't work it didn't work
and i know all these communi leftists
will be like it was because the u.s was
interfering with it
communism yeah so yeah when they were
like star of the ukrainians to give the
russians food because we need it more
i'm like
that's central planning so the women's
trading individual like traffic that
maybe since the problem is not that
they're making people do something or
making them
not do something it's that they're
restraining their ability to be
adaptable
because you need yeah that's what you
need to allow people centralization
strain their ability to be free yeah i
mean adaptability is freedom
and you know and then that's that's
taken away in a centralized system it's
it's interesting
uh max the other day was talking about
how these
these um alt coins like a casino
somebody says i put in money on this
cryptocurrency i lost money
and now i need to make it back up so
they put in a different currency they
keep losing money
i feel like a lot of the centralization
we see with these these wealthy
individuals is
they made a bet hey we should do this
policy and control this good
it'll make everything better then when
it gets worse they go quick quick do
another policy
and so they keep stacking duct tape onto
a thing the problem is caused by them
yeah yeah and you talked about how it's
a series of events that lead to the
ultimate collapse of society
and i think you're absolutely right but
if you look at one country in particular
and more should be written about there's
movies you talked about doing original
creative
oh we're doing it movies should be
written about this and it is in our
lifetime
the story of venezuela i mean in in the
turn of the century
this century the year 2000 it was the
the wealthiest most prosperous
country in south america uh um it had a
a
of of american and european engineers
and doctors who lived there
hugo chavez did not run as saying i'm
going to destroy your country he ran as
i'm going to bring a greater sense of
equality and equity or whatever whatever
and here we are 21 years later and 70
with the latest statistic i saw
78 of the population is in extreme
poverty
i mean they have the world's largest
proven oil and gas reserve
oil reserves and they have no they have
no oil not a murder though like a lot of
murder
exactly i mean i mean in every single
the
those who who those illuminati those who
were smart those who were
fled the country and what is left and
who takes care of those people and that
that
is i fear the direction we are slowly
headed in it's a series of collapse in
addition to the series of collapses what
happens
what tends to happen is it will affect
one large group of people and then those
people will
migrate because they're screwed and then
the migration will
cause another catastrophe where they
land and they'll disrupt those
that populace the sea people were the
ones that were catastrophically
affected by the series of events so it
seems but the people that were murdered
in the mediterranean just suffered the
fallout
so what you're basically saying is that
in these blue areas destroyed by
democrats they're all going to flood
into red area we're seeing it happen
and they're bringing their weird you
know race theories
it's like a drop of it it's it's landing
in schools in like west virginia
freaking out parents
yeah colorado yep and that's why
federalism is your best fight back
because you have so much more power at
this
power should be as concentrated at the
localist level possible and people
get rid of the electoral college you
know i mean without getting into the
history of our founding fathers
the person who's not elected by
electoral college is your governor
because that's where
more power should be than the president
they never wanted the president they
never wanted dc to be powerful
so did the founders love democracy they
loved direct democracy because they
wanted it at the most local your mayor
is elected by direct democracy
but boy wouldn't it be great if your
mayor had more power than your governor
and your governor more power than the
president but instead
they used to be an expression my mom i
hope you listen to mom she used to say
it all the time and maybe she's the last
one don't make a federal case out of it
everything is now a federal case my
trans daughter can't play volleyball
go to the supreme court holy crap
there's no other recourse
everything gets elevated to washington
dc
well it that's that that's it's like
we're asking you know mom and dad to
solve our problems for us
yeah that's it's an interesting thing
you know the problem is if people live
in these awful blue states
then they move to red states and then
start floating voting blue again and
then they just
you know keep yeah and then maybe we'll
move back to california one day and
reclaim it as our own
right i mean there are states that were
blue that have turned red and there are
states that are red that are turning
blue
and and i'm not gonna stop migration
patterns but you know california
had the largest exodus in the last 10
years
who knows maybe they'll drive it so far
into the ground people will start moving
back to california and reclaim it
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content
segments you can't get anywhere else go
to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you